Die AfD-Fraktionsvorsitzende und Oppositionsführerin
Alice Weidel hat mit ihrer Rede im Bundestag
am Mittwoch für Empörung gesorgt.
In der Generaldebatte warf Weidel der Bundesregierung
vor, mit einer ihrer Ansicht nach ungezügelten
Einwanderung vor allem von Muslimen den Wohlstand
zu gefährden.
"Sogar die Auffettung der Einwohnerzahl durch
zugewanderte Straftäter mit mehrfachen Identitäten
scheint Sie überhaupt nicht zu stören.
Doch, ich kann Ihnen sagen:
Burkas, Kopftuchmädchen und alimentierte
Messermänner und sonstige Taugenichtse werden
unseren Wohlstand, das Wirtschaftswachstum
und vor allem den Sozialstaat nicht sichern.
Wer soll in Zukunft für die Renten aufkommen?
Wer zahlt denn Ihre stattlichen Pensionen,
auch Ihre Herr Hofreiter, Sie Schreihals.
Ihre eingewanderten Goldstücke etwa?
Das glauben Sie doch wohl nicht im ernst."
Vertreter aller anderen Bundestagsparteien
reagierten mit lauten Zwischenrufen und buhten
Weidel aus.
Bundestagspräsident Wolfgang Schäuble rügte
Weidel:
"Sie haben in Ihrer Rede die Formulierung
- unter anderem - Kopftuchmädchen und sonstige
Taugenichtse gebraucht.
Damit diskriminieren Sie alle Frauen, die
ein Kopftuch tragen.
Dafür ruf ich Sie zur Ordnung."
Unions-Fraktionschef Volker Kauder von der
CDU kritisierte Weidel scharf für ihre Aussagen.
"Und wenn es dann in diesem Haus Kolleginnen
und Kollegen gibt, die das christliche Abendland
retten wollen und dann über andere Menschen
so sprechen, wie Sie es gemacht haben Frau Weidel,
hat dies mit christlichem Menschenbild nichts
zu tun.
Null hat es damit zu tun."
Kauder warf der AfD insgesamt vor, sie sei
zwar großmaulig im Austeilen dafür aber
schwach im Einstecken.